what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and it looks like we
were robbed quite a bit with doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
recently it has been revealed that they
cut two really really cool scenes from
multiverse of madness one of them
involving another fight between the
scarlet witch and doctor strange and
possibly even more evil variants of
doctor strange but the other deleted
scene involves nightmare one of the most
popular doctor strange villain who we
thought was going to be the main villain
of this movie who was supposed to be the
villain of the first movie but didn't
end up in either of the films although
we did think he was going to be at least
a villain in this movie especially with
the tease of doctor strange saying that
every day he has the same nightmare the
same with wanda it did certainly seem
like they were setting up the villain
nightmare to make at least an appearance
however it looks like in the end they
decided to go with the scarlet witch
being the main villain of the movie but
today we actually have a look at what it
could have been like if nightmare was
indeed in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness including what is
a deleted scene that was cut from the
movie involving doctor strange nightmare
and his sister who died falling through
the ice that they briefly mentioned at
the end of multiverse of madness now for
those of you who don't know originally
nightmare was supposed to be the main
villain of doctor strange number one
scott derrickson directed the first
movie and they wanted to do nightmare
but they decided to leave it for doctor
strange too and i don't know if some of
you remember this but originally scott
derrickson was supposed to direct doctor
strange 2 and doctor strange 2 was truly
supposed to be the mcu's first horror
film and this is something that scott
derrickson really really wanted to do so
the villain nightmare was really a
perfect fit however due to creative
differences scott derrickson backed out
of the project now from what we
understand the creative differences were
scott derrickson really wanted a true
horror film but kevin foggy of course
said this still needs to be pg-13 we
can't go full rated r we can't do all of
the true horror stuff that you want to
do based off of everything that we've
heard that's what happened so then they
brought in sam raimi and honestly doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
was still pretty creepy but we didn't
see nightmare in the movie however we
almost did but they cut it out of the
movie but here we have some actual
photos from what would have been in the
movie and some photos of nightmare and
how he would have looked if we saw him
in multiverse of madness now this is set
design here using figures so as you can
see here we have doctor strange standing
on a frozen lake and we have nightmare
standing on a horse in front of him now
we'll go back to this in just a second
but first let's go to this look at
nightmare in the book now this is what
marvel studios labeled this book it says
nightmare character ancient text and
illustrations this is something
apparently labeled as a dream codex and
it shows nightmare in what looks to be
medieval armor riding a horse there's a
lot of drawings also in the background
in the upper left it seems like it could
be the cycles of the moon but we also do
have another page of this dream codex
that looks a little bit different
showing him in different armor this one
looks a lot more cool and it actually
shows him in samurai armor riding more
of a traditional horse and he has four
horns on his head and there's a lot of
text on this book that is really just
too small to make out but here we are
getting our first look at what nightmare
would have looked like in multiverse of
madness but going back to doctor strange
and nightmare being on the frozen lake
here we have actually multiple scales of
the set that they were designing and
here's where we find out what the scene
with nightmare was originally intended
to be in the film before they actually
made the decision to cut it and it does
appear to be a scene on a frozen lake
with dr strange's sister donna strange
now like i said they ultimately did kind
of mention this scene at the end of
doctor strange where he's fighting with
sinister strange doctor strange talks
about the time where he was on the lake
with his sister donna who would go on to
fall through the ice and sadly die now
that happens no matter what however here
it looks like nightmare is sort of
haunting doctor strange and giving him
nightmares about when his sister died
and the fact that doctor strange could
not save her but the coolest thing here
is it actually looks like doctor strange
was going to fight nightmare we see
nightmare on the horse and it looks like
he is wearing the costume and the armor
from the second design the more samurai
looking armor and across from him we see
doctor strange ready to fight so sadly
it looks like we were deprived of a
doctor strange versus nightmare fight
now like i mentioned they originally
teased us with nightmare in the trailers
where we heard doctor strange and wanda
say nightmare so it's probably safe to
assume that they did really intent on
this scene being in the movie but as we
know they cut multiple scenes and doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness was
only a little bit over two hours long it
was relatively short compared to what
we've gotten recently from marvel
studios but perhaps they are saving this
scene for another doctor strange movie
clia has now been introduced into the
mcu we know that incursions are
happening so we know that we are going
to be getting a doctor strange 3 and
even though there's going to be a lot
going on with those incursions and such
they're still going to need a villain
and perhaps nightmare has just been
pushed back to doctor strange 3.
hopefully we get nightmare at some point
in time because in this picture in this
book he does look pretty awesome and now
doctor strange honestly has even more
things to have nightmares about
christine palmer is now married he had
to essentially kill himself even though
it was an evil variant and he had to
watch a lot of sorcerers die at the
hands of wanda so nightmare could
definitely still be used in another film
so fingers crossed that we see him now
there was another scene that was cut
from this movie that involved a fight
between doctor strange america chavez
and the scarlet witch and i think i
would have actually been more interested
in seeing this scene than what we got on
the screen in the movie america chavez
gets scared she opens up a portal and
her and doctor strange go through the
portal no one else the scarlet witch
doesn't go through wang doesn't go
through it is just doctor strange and
america chavez they go through a bunch
of different universes until they
eventually land into the universe where
the illuminati exist and they meet mordo
but sadly we found out that this scene
was originally supposed to be doctor
strange and wanda going at it something
that we didn't actually truly see in
multiverse of madness a one-on-one fight
between doctor strange and wanda now we
did kind of get undead strange fighting
wanda but we didn't get a full-on doctor
strange at his best fighting wanda in
this scene the star portal opens and
strange and the scarlet witch jump in
the portal after america chavez they
released a ton of concept art for this
fight right here and as you can see we
do have doctor strange and wanda going
toe to toe now this would have been
quite the scene because as we know wanda
is pretty much just a pure raw magic raw
power user that is how she fights but
doctor strange is a little bit more
seasoned a little bit more skilled he's
not as powerful as wanda but he is a
little bit more knowledgeable about
magic now ultimately this scene would
have been sorcery versus witchcraft
which would have been some pretty dang
cool stuff to see however sadly they
went a different route for whatever
reason ultimately strange and america
chavez would be the only ones to go
through the portal and wanda would
remain at the carmitage and from there
she would torture poor wong and use the
darkhold to dreamwalk perhaps that
couldn't have happened if this scene
happened since wanda wasn't there
although she could have always just gone
back just the pure raw strength of
wanda's magic kind of makes it to where
she can pretty much do almost anything
she wants and if she wanted to go back
to the carmitage after traveling through
the multiverse it probably wouldn't have
been too hard however she would have
needed america chavez to somehow open up
a portal for her to get back and that's
where the problem lies and that is
probably why this scene was ultimately
scrapped however i do wish we would have
gotten a fight scene like this of wanda
going up against doctor strange
one-on-one toe-to-toe both in their
normal states not doctor strange as a
zombie i would have loved to see that
and i definitely think we were robbed
but hey let me know what you think about
these two deleted scenes that we didn't
get in multiverse of madness would you
have liked to have seen them and perhaps
maybe we will even get a nightmare scene
and a nightmare villain in a future
doctor strange movie but let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest mcu news for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof